more than 150 people are feared to have
drowned in northwest nigeria
after a ferry sank on the niger river
around 165 people are believed to have
been on board
when the boat capsized it was traveling
from
central niger state to kebbi state where
witnesses say it broke into pieces and
sank
let's head straight over to lagos now
for the latest our correspondent fred
mavunia is standing by there
fred what more can you tell us about the
rescue effort
do authorities think they have any
chance of pulling any more people
alive from the water
well tell the chances to put out more
people
alive it's uh according to officials
from there in
uh kebab state they were saying that
this is this is unlikely because
the incident happened this accident
happened
uh yesterday at ten o'clock local time
and and they believe that people are
still under water
so the chances of uh getting them alive
it's it's really almost impossible
that's what he said he said and the
operation
went on until uh midnight and then they
stopped and they restarted again this
morning hoping to
hoping that they can get more bodies
from the water
now the boat was apparently overcrowded
when it sank
is that likely the main cause
that's what the officials are saying
because this boat
normally should carry around uh 80
people but
we understand that the number was more
than
more than double some numbers uh some of
uh
newspapers are saying 200 people others
are saying more than 180
but the state officials count 165 women
and and kids who were on this boat going
to a market
so definitely they are saying that the
main cause for this accident
is that the boat was overloaded and uh
not only people but also even some of uh
some of things that they were taking to
the market we're also on board
so definitely that's one of the reason
but also another reason is that
these boats are very very very old
now these kinds of accidents these boat
accidents are
not that uncommon unfortunately in
nigeria could authorities be doing
more to prevent them
yeah obviously people are saying that
the water transport
transport policy should officials should
work on it and try to see
what they can change because anyone who
wants to do business in water transport
they just go there and do it and they
have odd boats there are no safety
measures
and uh officials barely control this
so that's why
fred thank you so much that uh good to
see you again by the way that was
our correspondent fred mavonier in lagos